ظرف الدموع يومها كلهم او اغلبهم وحينها
كان هو يبلغ من العمر 9 سنوات فكان شاهدا
على المساء ماساهم
القصه الشهيره حين اخفقت بلاد السامبا في
معانقه لقبها الاول والكاس بين ظهرانيه
في مشهد يقض مضاجع البرازيليين الى يوم
الناس هذا ولم يكن ذلك الفتى الاسطوري
المفجوع سواء اديسون رنتيس دون اسمنتو
الشهير بعد ذلك بيبلي لتبدا مذاك رحله
التميز ولنقل معانقه المجد من كل اطرافه
جاء كاس العالم في السويد عام 58 وكان ابن
سينا يكاد يبلغ 17 من عمره لكن ذلك لم
يمنعه من ان يقدم نفسه في احسن ما يكون
فنال اللقب العالميه مع باقي الرفاق انجاز
سيتكرر في المونديال التالي حين حسم هو
منتخبه اللقب في التشيلي وما هي الى
استراحه سنوات ثمان حتى نضج اللاعب
الاسطوره ليجعل من محطه مونديال المكسيك
عام 70 موعدا لا ينسى توجته البرازيل
بنجمه ثالثه خالده واحتفظت بكاس جول ريمي
مره والى الابد
يجد نفسه بالي مفتقدا للحافز فيقرر الرحيل
الى الولايات المتحده في صفقه قيل حينها
انها ستجلب المنفعه للطرفين جنا منها
اللاعب الاسطوري سته ملايين دولار في عقد
مع فريق نيويورك
بلاد العم سام في ذلك خطوه جباره لبسطي
عشق الساحره المستديره في تلك البلاد لم
يقل مقام الاسطوره كثيرا فقرر الاعتزال
عام 77 لكن الصفحه حقا لم تطوى لقد اضحى
بليل ايقونه كل الاجيال وما زال حتى وقد
تجاوز عمره 80 حوله بليه الجوهره السوداء